m
nous sommes chez la coloc à terre les
jeunes pascal pascal et basse caleçon
dans la cuisine et rien ne semble les
inquiéter pourtant il devrait en effet
une invasion de bactéries se prépare
secrètement ces dernières tentent de se
reproduire sans se faire remarquer au
fil des jours les bactéries deviennent
de plus en plus entreprenante
tentant pro milieu des actions minimes
et furtif de sabotage sur les membres de
la colocataire
tout d'abord c'est pascal qui ont subi
les frais
trois heures depuis son entrée dans les
toilettes et toujours aucun signe de vie
ensuite
c'est pascal suite à la gorge stations à
sec malcuit qui se plaint de mal de vent
c'était plus qu'un simple mal de ventre
là entre temps la colocataire se doute
que quelque chose se tramait que cette
chose ne veut pas génial pour contrer la
menace alimentaire qui viennent
d'identifier il décide de nettoyer la
cuisine sérieux légal une nuit pour
essayer de nous aider mais la menace est
toujours là il reprend de plus belle
cette fois à colocataires ne se fera pas
avoir en effet un dispositif se met en
marche les aliments crus et cuits seront
coupés à part au plan de travail sur un
toit y est après chaque utilisation
cependant une dernière chose à faire
façade pour la colocataire
les éléments impropre à la consommation
sont erratiques et les bonnes
résolutions sont respectés et que
l'autre était de plus en danger il en y
reprendra plus
la fait du bon boulot
adieu